okay well done
okay we're live all right we're
officially live with podcast episode
number 31 back with tom
and adam today gents how are you good
good to see you guys you're doing good
get that together by the way you guys
missed it tom was just saying that uh
leonardo dicaprio is the
greatest actor of your generation the
last 20 years i did say that yes
what movie favorite movie of his you
know my point is that in
any role he's in he's so believable i
mean i was just talking about this with
my daughter the other day i was going
you know the dude gets so much pub for
the young models and everything in
titanic but
man when you think about it he is a
great actor catch me if you can
uh once upon a time in hollywood uh
everything he's been in i mean
the list is long the one where he carved
or crawled into a bear carcass whatever
that one was
that was pretty neat he got the academy
award that was pretty legit and that was
his first remember how he held the uh
academy
do you remember how he hailed the
academy when he won what do you do
you don't remember this here's how we
held it have you seen a picture of me
the trophy the oscar yeah
he don't he held this card like this and
he looked at the academy like this you
don't remember
with the middle finger out here yeah
because all these years they never gave
him one
anyways he had me at blood diamond seen
blood
i like the fact that you never choose
the best of them really you gotta like
like how you do that okay so that is on
fire today
we got shout out to you i don't know pat
is on we got a lot
we got a lot of stuff to cover today a
lot of stuff to cover today
the reason why we're talking about the
dicaprio let's get this knocked out of
the way it's a big announcement he's
officially going to be a daddy at 46
and mommy is 23. that's one of the
reasons why we're talking about are we
breaking the news here is that
and you were telling you what were you
saying you were saying how in the hell
did he all these years
never get anybody pregnant that's what
you were talking about let's pull out
game is strong there you go it is what
it is something i'm not good at
okay all right uh uh okay all right all
right that's what happens man when you
get three kids and two more on the way
that's i i have not mastered that
ability here's our topics today
goldman sparks florida's effort to
become wall street
south goldman sachs planning on leaving
one of their divisions to go to florida
we'll talk about that oh yeah
dwayne johnson's tequila company on pace
for record-breaking
first year of sales that include b that
includes beating uh
clooney right i think he's kicking
clooney's butt right now would you be
willing to take the covet shot for 1500
bucks that's what they're talking about
kyle we'll give you fifteen hundred
dollars to take the covet shot you're
gonna do it eric
sam will you take the kovitch shot for
1500 eric's doing that the government's
trying to bribe you
to take the code that's comfortable yeah
very much so silicon valley elites are
moving to florida
but vc's told the mayor that a state law
needs to change before
moore would relocate a slap in a face la
restaurant oh no video we'll share with
you that's going to be pretty epic
heartfelt video restaurants unite
against mission coronavirus restrictions
nasdaq c seek a board's diversity rule
that most listed firms don't meet
rashida jones named the president of
msnbc becoming the first black leader of
cable news network
uh and then we got trump talking about
plans of a made for
tv exit on air force one from the white
house to a rally on inauguration day
hoping to pull viewers from biden it's
kind of like
uh uh what lebron james did leaving uh
uh
to miami times a million the
announcement yeah the announcement
senators uh behind a bipartisan 908
billion alakova stimulus
plan say they're close to an agreement
which is good news for many
sanders criticized it matthew
mcconaughey unfortunately is getting
pushed around a little bit in hollywood
for slamming hollywood's hypocrisy over
2020 election results
trump to sign a first made uh executive
order
he plans on running 2024 kova changing
the quarantine time
there's a logan paul mayweather fight
coming up logan paul you got to respect
those guys
and for those of you there were people
that were very concerned about comey
never getting a job again
comey officially got a job as a
professor at columbia
law school i know you were concerned
about it i was going to say like a
doorman somewhere
you know a bouncer we'll talk about that
so that's what we have and on top of
that and on top of that
we got some interesting topics that i
sent you do you have all of them i sent
you two other articles by the way
if you want to get them ready for uh
china uh but before we do that
here's what i want to do once you just
pull up the first video of the lady who
runs a
restaurant in california sherman oaks
california not too far from an
hour away from the hour 15 minutes away
from you sherman oaks california
who this happened to her and
you're gonna feel i mean this video on
twitter's already got nine million views
her uh gofundme right now what is her
gofundme ad right now
has it crossed two hundred thousand
dollars i think i think it's 150
yesterday it was uh
yeah when we did the video yesterday it
was 107. let's see where it's at now
uh a second one there you go 164
okay good for she's the one in the
middle and here's what happened to her
um play the video take a look at this
folks
she runs a sushi spot so this is my
place the pineapple hill grill in saloon
if you go to my page you can see all the
work i did
for outdoor dining for tables being
seven feet apart
and i come in today because i'm
organizing a protest
and i came in to get stuff for that
and i walk into my parking lot and
obviously
mayor garcetti has approved
[Music]
this adam have you seen this i have not
okay this is good
tom you've seen it okay watch this
this being set up for this
being set up for for a movie company
a movie movie
everything i own is being taken away
from me and they set up a movie company
right next to my outdoor patio which is
right over here
how do you justify it i wonder why i'm
protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot
survive my staff cannot survive look at
this
look how far apart they are tell me that
this is dangerous 20 yards yeah but
right next to me
as a slap in my face
that's safe this is safe
50 feet away
this is dangerous mayor garcetti and
gavin newsom is responsible
for every single person that doesn't
have unemployment
that does not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under
and we need your help we need somebody
to do something about this
you know that's more powerful than if
they had scripted it oh no
listen when i first saw that i was so
mad
i mean i could not believe what i was
watching and hearing i could not believe
it and it brought it all to life
do you know how much she spent
renovating her deck to get it ready
eighty thousand dollars 80 grand she
paid
to renovate that i know so many stories
like that garcetti is such
a prick i just can't even believe it
when you heard his
reaction to this my heart goes out to
her and
that's all he said no thoughts no offer
to assist them in any way
it's it's the beginning uh they they are
trying to
legislate fun out of people's lives i
really believe that i think they have
chosen the restaurant industry to
demolish it for some reason
in some of these states in california
for sure i mean it's unbelievable
manhattan beach
you know we were talking about that last
week these guys are smart because you
know the same thing you can't have
outdoor dining there in every restaurant
there's a lot of great restaurants there
and they all have outdoor dining
they've designated all their outdoor
decks as public parks
so now you can get your take out and go
sit out there so they found a little
loophole and i'm sure
city hall has taken off about it i'm
sure l.a county's not happy about it but
man she's a star now she was on fox
yesterday she was as compelling on neil
cavuto's show yesterday she was there
i mean she is going to be the face of
this movement from coast to coast
michigan watch what's happening there
new york same thing it's uh it's just
the beginning of what's going on
so three quick things how do you number
one how do you not feel for that lady
i mean i don't care whether you're where
you stand politically
mass no mask left right up down
the lady's pouring her heart out right
there if you don't feel for her like
you're missing something going on in
your life so
yeah i got the chills just watching her
that's number one number two
the outdoor dining thing really
california is that absurd that they're
shutting down
outdoor dining like we've we all had
lunch we we were in manhattan beach
there's a big difference between indoor
dining and social distancing and all
that and outdoor dining i mean
that i've said the same thing
continuously i don't understand why
they're shutting down outdoor
restaurants like hers
especially when she set up a specific
area for people to eat and i mean the
hypocrisy of setting up a movie company
i mean you couldn't again couldn't have
scripted that any better and then here's
i guess my third point you said that the
mayor responded
it's on you buddy it's on you to make a
move now after seeing that that is a
tangible example
are you just gonna sort of be like oh my
heart goes out to you and give the
standard quote
are you actually going to say something
to that specific situation because
there's a case example
of how you are messing up buddy i'm sure
there's a million different case
examples but that is now live in effect
you ever been to a funeral
yes you ever been to a funeral where a
person
uh uh you know you go to funerals and
then there's funerals what i mean by
that is you go to funerals but
everybody's very amicable
and it was kind of like yeah hey you
know what sorry man this i'm sorry hey
you know all this other stuff
you ever go to a funeral where somebody
is crying and you
fully feel the pain with zero
acting no drama you ever been to you
brought up a story like that uh last
weekend
yeah i mean you go to funerals like this
that's what happened that's a that's her
funeral right there
that's the small business's funeral you
just saw that but she's slapping the
face
of course it's a slap in the face
because it was caused by something that
could have been prevented that's the
stuff that's annoying
that's when politics gets gets in and
gets dirty right that's when somebody
like that takes a hit
but by the way you're what people don't
realize is
you know you can only go so far doing
this we're going to keep showing this
stuff every time a video like this comes
up we're going to show it and we should
how much money does she raise
200 grand i think sometimes 160 000
right is that a lot of money
for her yes in general okay check this
out that's after 9.1 million views
she only raised 164 000. so that means
you need to rate you need to have a
video go viral like this to be able to
raise that kind of money
how about the rest of the people that
don't get this kind of exposure how
about the rest of the people that don't
have a video like that that gets picked
up and goes on tv how about the rest of
the
how about those guys how about the
people that don't have a platform and
don't go communicate and they don't get
picked up by anybody how about that yeah
nobody talks about them they do you
think they're going to be able to raise
200 000
100 no they're just having to shut down
now she's going to make it
she's gonna be okay because eighty
thousand dollars she spent on her deck
she's getting that back
and more and she can shut down for a
couple months and pay some of her
workers
and say guys let's just kick back she'll
be known as the restaurant
but how about the rest of the thousands
that nothing can be done about coast to
coast i have an idea yeah i'm gonna
throw this out there right now why don't
valuetainment why don't we do a telethon
like they do after a big disaster after
a hurricane we should do a telethon for
the restaurant industry we could raise
them tens and tens of millions
i think that's a great idea i would
actually be very open to that for
getting but
we would need to collect the stories i'd
want to get people from across i'd love
to be able to do something like that
because
for me my concern isn't her she's fine
she's officially fine
she's officially gonna be gonna be known
as what the restaurant
so you're going to go eat there
intentionally just to do what i want to
support your business
right but the rest of them are the ones
that are going to take a massive hit
that's not going to change why is it
that the restaurant industry you said
that you thought that the restaurant
industry was single-handedly
being singled out what is it about they
have to answer that because they have
singled it out and i'll tell you what
there's a couple tipping points coming
up
wednesday there's a strong powerful
group of restaurant owners in la i mean
it's a great restaurant city and these
guys are ticked off
so they went to la county and the judge
was told the county that by wednesday
you have to come back here
and prove that there's contact tracing
that this is dangerous that you actually
have the data
to prove that outdoor dining is
spreading covet so wednesday is the day
to watch
because if they can't do that the judge
might just open up the outdoor dining
for everybody here's the other thing i
say
it's going to lead to violence look
what's happening in michigan the way
whitmer is shutting down restaurants and
everything right there those people
don't play out there i mean they have
militias remember they almost tried to
abduct the governor and they have the
kids to kill her it's going to let's do
it thomas let's do it
let's do it let's kidnap it right when
you see that pain on her face
multiply that by probably a million
people around the country that work in
the restaurant industry
she literally said on fox yesterday she
had two employees
family members or new two people that
committed suicide that killed themselves
since this began someone is homeless
because of this and this is just in her
little small circle
and they don't give a damn about it
which is just disgusting you said a
million people that work in a restaurant
industry
it's not a million people you know what
the number is more than that it's 30
million people
it's it's not a small number 10 percent
of americans work in the service
industry
10 percent of americans work in the
service industry check out bars
everything you're talking about 15 to 30
million they say as high as
50 million at one point have contributed
towards that industry like we've all
worked in in that industry i've worked
in this you worked in the industry
before
you know pat the other thing too is it's
not like these restaurant owners they
tried to do with that guy in staten
island
you know he called his bar an autonomous
zone and tried to keep it open the city
went there
he raised 80 grand he did he raised some
money too but they're playing with fire
because they're all dictated by licenses
liquor licenses right and things like
that food and beverage licenses
the state can shut them down so easy so
it's not like they can just this is very
important for you to repeat one more
time folks
pay very close attention what time just
said right there say say what you just
said
one more time right because if they want
to protest and say screw you government
we're just going to open our doors and
we don't care the state
can just shut them down because they all
have liquor licenses they have licenses
to serve
food to have outdoor dining areas so the
state has them man
that is mafia at the highest level their
doors stay open contingent on the
licensing being uh they'd yank them in a
second
they pull them right away but something
something to add you know we've talked
about this recovery and obviously the
stock market has bounced back and then
some
is the v shaped is it the k shape what
kind of u-shape is the l-shape
this is a clear indication of this
k-shaped economy where the rich get
richer
and people that work in the insurance
business or the financial services
business
or anything where you could work from
home you'll be okay you can work from
home but anything that you need to get
out of your house
yeah and work in the service-based
industry whether it's restaurants bars
clubs
all that cruise ships anything travel
related hospitality that's the you know
the bottom half of the k-shaped economy
and those people are struggling right
now and that's why congress needs to
frickin
act and get their act together and pass
this trillion dollar bill but that's not
going to solve every problem think about
these people man
they also live in california where rent
is high taxes are high
it's it's a desperate it's crazy the two
places that are taking the biggest hit
is new york and california
those are the two places that are cost
of living is you know out of this world
you know i lived there for a long time
you know what it is to live in
california it's not cheap living over
there it's very expensive to be living
over there so
that leads me to the next story which is
goldman sachs so here's goldman sachs
when you think about goldman sachs you
only think about one state you think
about one city new york new york city
you know
you don't think about anything else it's
new york goldman sachs right
new york goldman sachs and elliott
management corp
are breathing new life into the decade
old idea of converting the miami to west
palm beach corridor into a southern hub
for finance and investing a notion that
would have
monumental implications for the area's
development
now goldman is weighing a new florida
for its asset management on while
billionaire paul singer's 41 billion
dollar hedge fund
elliott management corp plans to move
its headquarters to west palm beach
according to
people familiar with discussions
trailblazing blazing moves by industry
giants could open the floodgates of
other firms
many of which have been hesitant to
leave the center of finance
financial universe for the promise of
better can you imagine if these guys
make them
look carl icahn recently decided to
relocate his asset management from
to florida ken griffin citadel plans to
open an office in miami mexico according
to
a person with knowledge of his plans you
know elon musk just told a few friends
that he's leaving california for texas
elon musk is telling his friends
in an interview a few months ago he said
no i'm not leaving california just
recently his friends imagine you're
having dinner with your friends saying
ilan are you ever going to leave
california i'm thinking about moving to
texas and friends are saying man you
know you're
thinking about moving to texas they're
thinking there is no consequences but
people are going to be leaving
what happens if a goldman leaves to
florida it's we talk about this every
week we're shocked that a company's
moving and then it's every week there's
a new one
and it's a bigger one and it's a higher
profile one
these government leaders in sacramento
california and is albany the capital of
new york is it albany
they must be so myopic and so stupid
and not have enough people around them
to challenge them on anything
this is a crisis of epic proportions for
these states it's as big as the pandemic
if you ask me
when you have companies leave because
the pandemic is eventually going to end
right there's going to have a vaccine
things eventually will slow down and get
back to normal
you have these companies bolting i mean
multiply this tax revenue
year by year by year and then you have
these high earners that aren't paying
individual income tax into the state and
why wouldn't they all move to texas and
florida
there's no state income tax i mean i
cannot believe
that they aren't treating this like the
crisis that it is because
it is only the biggest thing behind
closed doors what do you think he's
doing
i think he's thinking about his book i'm
thinking about the next interview he's
doing i think that
yes i do i'm almost very aware of this
he begged and pleaded
look i'll cook you dinner remember that
quote yeah i remember that look come
over i'll cook you dinner
don't leave uh cuomo's aware of this i
don't think he's immune to this but
at the same time you know this says this
decades-old
um breathing new life into this
decades-old idea this is not a new idea
of new yorkers basically thinking about
coming down tomorrow but now they're
actually doing it
relax i got you tom i'm fired up
this is this is nothing new i feel like
they've been playing hopscotch for a
while look
born and raised in miami i've lived in
my entire life um i know a lot of people
that
basically i mean half my friends have
been like yeah man i just couldn't do it
in new york especially when they have
kids
especially when they have kids you can
be single and have a time of your
freaking life in new york city run
around
you meet a girl you meet a guy next
thing you know you have kids you're
thinking i'm living in a freaking shoe
box i'm paying five thousand dollars a
month here what the [ __ ] am i doing
hold on for five grand a month i can get
a sick house
on the water in boca raton or in west
palm or in miami in fort lauderdale
whatever
and i feel like for years for decades
people have been sort of playing
hopscotch with
you know or what's that what's the jump
rope game when you you know you're kind
of like
thinking about going thinking about
going next thing double dutch thank you
who was that
um eric you're thinking about doing
double dutch
boom pandemic happens and then they're
thinking dude i've been thinking about
this for years now
i'm talking about just individuals
forget about corporations we can we can
talk about corporations as well
they've been thinking about it forever
now and now the pandemic happens they're
like screw it
what do we have to [ __ ] lose so
here's the question here's a question
down
what keeps p i get what keeps people in
california i totally get it i mean if
you've been there we went there the
weather we're hanging out with shawna
listen the weather i lived there 20 some
years beautiful what
what keeps people in new york well look
number one there's still
it's talking about individuals or
corporations both what keeps people in
new york
it is the financial corporations okay
talent talent
yeah like i live in miami you cannot
compare the brain power
and the talent in new york versus miami
miami's got a lot of favorable things
going
this way clearly the weather the weather
the weather the weather the low taxes
the fun the sun all that
you'd be very hard-pressed to find a
very intellectual conversation going to
miami bro
it's not going to happen for the most
part bro like there's just not that
level of brain trust in miami it's
changing though
it's changing um what else is keeping
people in new york i mean
look no doubt and and jerry seinfeld did
did a thing about this where he's like
look you could
you could say that new york is you know
dying and nobody's coming back to new
york
new york is still the best city in the
country in my opinion straight up
as far as like but what why dude i mean
was the last time you just hung out
don't get me wrong listen i love you i'm
not i i
love but i'm asking you why my favorite
thing to do in this world and
you're talking about somebody who's born
and raised in miami loves miami if
there's one place i could live
year round it'd be miami because i just
can't take the sure
but my favorite thing to do is just put
on some earbuds
and just walk around new york city so
here's a question just walk around
or to live for a vacation okay so but
i'm saying why do people
live and stay inside your question
because 12 years out of the year
12 months i say you have we have some
it's culture that's what i was going to
say i was going to say culture culture
and then
everybody the belief that you are in the
epicenter of the world i mean new york
is where
everything happens or at least it used
to be so i think that kept people there
feel of fear of missing out you know
professionally if you live somewhere
else
it's just not the same or it hasn't been
i mean the buzz and the excitement of
new york
i think if you look if you look at the
the look at cuomo's attitude
look at trump's attitude look at new
york's attitude
right there's an attitude about new york
it's very attractive
the attitude of new york it's like no
here's what i'm going to do
and we're going to figure out a way you
don't like you know it's like it's a you
can make it there you can make it anyway
very you know unique attitude about that
attitude does not exist in miami i'm
telling you but that what i'm trying to
tell you is
i've done business with people from
every state i've done business with
people from every state
every religion pretty much you can think
i've done business with everybody right
there's something very unique about
doing business with people from new york
i love doing business with people from
new york
the way they are you're going to know
very quickly if
something's going to happen or not it's
not like well can i get you something
would you like to see that hey mary can
you get us something it's like
so listen you know when i look at what
you got going on and what we got going
on i think there's something here what
do you think how about we do this i
think it's really only the
beggar it's just a very simple open
conversation with them they have but
that talent
is transferable to any market you take
that talent to a market like florida you
got a big upside
oh yeah yeah big upside right and so you
go to florida a state with no taxes
weather year-round yesterday we're
looking at checking out the weather last
night in palm beach
64 degrees it hit 47 yesterday people
are freaking palm beach
they're freaking out iguanas are dying
that's freezing that's the point
yeah iguanas are dying they're freezing
right yeah real stories i know you're
telling me this
so but 60 46 in new york is like a
youtube channel we got kobe tom's got 46
in new york so yeah so you know you
people people don't think
anyone's going to leave new york until
they do yep
that's that's really what it is there's
a gallop behind them you know a couple
other things now with all these people
and all these corporations leaving new
york what's gonna have to happen they're
gonna have to raise taxes
for the people that stay there right i
mean isn't that logical that it's gonna
even get worse
yeah adam you know i'm with you man as
far as like hanging out in new york
there's nothing like it
last time i was in new york was in
february and that was right
i would say like a week before the
pandemic and i already noticed it was
different i really did i think de blasio
has done such damage to that city i mean
they need a mayor like giuliani to come
in there and restore that city
because well that was new york in the
70s in the giuliani of the 90s or
giuliani of today the 90s
the big difference yeah yeah that guy's
a mess right now by the way if you're
watching this you're listening to this
what do you think about it what keeps
people in new york what keeps people in
new york why don't people want to leave
new york i mean obviously
the the slow slow what the pandemic did
it exposed states like california and
new york
in a big way pandemic was not good for
california new york by the way no
horrible
horrible for those two states can i make
one last point sure and i really truly
mean this
i believe you look at these two states
by far handling the pandemic the worst
the worst
situation the worst stories we hear are
in california new york
i believe that cuomo thinks he's a rock
star i really do the interviews the
books i think he's thinking of what's
going on for him i i truly believe he's
thinking more about what's next
and i think the same thing about newsome
i don't think they care enough about
what's going on
they're thinking about their next move
newsom newsome's thinking about being
president
cuomo is thinking about being a rock
star and whatever else is coming up
after and they're neglecting things that
are happening right now because they're
so selfish
who do you think will be president first
who has a higher likelihood of being
president
cuomo or newsome i go cuomo tell me why
uh i think he's got a broader appeal
i think look you think that uh cuomo's
hand uh new york's handling the pandemic
worse
i think i think between garcetti and
and uh newsom they're freaking disaster
new york in essence this is where the
pandemic started all right so thinking
about people are living within
like shoe boxes of each other like
that's a lot
harder to deal with people are living on
living on living on people right on top
of people
versus l.a is completely spread out yeah
like you can eat outdoor
no problem weather's fine you can deal
with this new york it's freezing you're
living on top of each other
totally different beast totally
different beast and
so you're saying cuomo before new song
i'm just saying do you think america is
ready for a single president
is he not married he's not married
what's going on there
you can read into it i'm not going to
talk about it i don't think he's got the
lindsey graham thing going on
do you is that's common knowledge what's
up with lindsey graham lindsey graham
thing
oh you know put it this way i wouldn't
be shocked if lindsey graham was one of
those 25 guys hanging out in hungarian
origin
you think so oh yeah you think he
parties in hungary
so go back to it so do you think america
is ready for a single president
look do you think america let me tell
you i'm being i'm back by the way look
but listen
the things that are going on in america
right now ready for a crappy president
so yeah a single one will be fine
foreign that's crazy i agree with you
tom
so so so wait a minute i'm actually
asking a serious question when john
kennedy was running everybody said is
america ready for a catholic president
and the answer was what yes is america
ready for a barack obama
yes is america ready for a woman to be a
president is america ready for a single
man to be a president
yeah well as far as a single man let me
tell you something
the guy's going to have no shortage of
ladies being like look
you know i see you're saying that's not
what i'm asking you i'm asking you does
america care
do you care if your president is single
or not america doesn't give you do you
care do you care
care less do you care do you care no you
don't don't
literally be competent clearly you care
no no i'm asking clearly you care
i tell you it's not about me there's
eight men in here not one
we also we all know we all said no but
what about you
you think you're going somewhere with
you i know you're going you think late
you think women are going to be saying
100 yes i don't know about that
i don't it's going to be like i don't
know i think you know how can you relate
to me if you don't have a family
he's never been married he's been
married okay
what are we talking about then he's got
kids he's not married today wow
gives a [ __ ] they smart then he he picks
up so what you're saying is you don't
give a sh
if you're watching this by the way i'm
asking you this if you really don't care
if the president is single put thumbs up
if you care for the president to be
married
put thumbs down they've all acted like
they were single anyway yeah everybody
i got my friend vince you know vince he
just i got a random text from him he
said
lindsey graham definitely putts from the
rough shout out to vince richardson
that's my guy how would vince know
though
vince's got some inroads he knows what's
going on maybe he's hosted the parties
vince is in touch with the people he
knows is in touch with the people
but i don't think bottom line is i don't
think anyone cares well look the reason
why i'm bringing this up
because bloomberg is single and he ran
and nobody brought it up and it wasn't a
topic it wasn't like something hey
you know is anybody you know going to
bring that up and it was never brought
up no but quite frankly bloomberg man on
the debate stage he was god he was a
putts
he had charisma he had swag maybe he was
style
you could tell he had all sorts of
energy yeah you agree with me right
bloomberg he had what trump damn good by
the way that that comment right there
could be used if he was running today
they would use that for one of them
he's got charisma he's mike bloomberg if
you want to pay me for that quote
you can reach me at value media okay so
dwayne johnson's about to be billionaire
just so everybody knows of course he's
already making 80 to 120 million dollars
a year as an actor highest paid actor in
the world
but on top of that his terra mana is
preparing to sell 300 000 9 liter cases
and ship nearly 400 000 cases
in its first year comparing johnson on
social media to george clooney randy
gerber and michael meldman sold their
their tequila brand to spirits
giant diagram diagio's at 175 000 cases
a year
reportedly 4 billion dollars their our
entire terra mana team and myself are
quite pleased and humble that the brand
is experiencing
this incredible off the charts success
he told forbes but we also recognize
there's much more work to be done we're
building a mana fuel legacy brand and
i'm
in for the long call so what do you
think you know what here was my first
reaction
um copycat this is boring another
another
superstar a-list actor trying to gravy
train off
george clooney and randy gerber's
success then you peel back you know the
ryan
ryan reynolds did it right he had the
gin he had aviation gin he sold that for
610 million there really is some money
in this
spirits business but then i i peel back
and and i see what the rock is selling
this tequila for
and he's still in a bottle between 29
and like 39 bucks
and casa amigos is like if you can get
it on sale it's like 46.
it's expensive it's a lot of money so i
give
him all the credit in the world now i'm
a fan he flipped me i
my initial thought was man do i really
need another a-list star that thinks
he's a tequila distributor i mean
i found it boring i found it cliche
actually but man he's killing it
it also shows the power of the rock
because i haven't seen one commercial
for this company i haven't heard one ad
on the radio
so it's all his social media that's
driving this thing and it just shows the
power that whatever he touches
you know it's going to explode and it's
unbelievable that that thing is selfish
you know there's this one app called
instagram yeah it's crazy and if you're
on this instagram
yeah there's this guy named dwayne the
rock johnson
don't follow and he has like 200 million
people that follow you know
and he posts videos of people that buy
his tequila every day
and he posts like 10 of them and people
having it and celebrate you've never
heard of this before i haven't i have it
so the rock is a big deal by the way
who's the rock he is this
good-looking actor who's got swagger at
the highest level
alpha yet you're a fan of the rock i
think he is
the kind of guy you root for you cheer
for you bring up the rock quite
you want to see this guy win you do he
listen
you cannot teach charisma and have it at
the level this guy's got do you think it
was a bad move that he came out and you
know did his whole anti-trump thing
no i don't think i think because he's
planning on running he just told you
which side of the aisle he's going to
run when he runs that's all he did
he's going to be a democrat what that
told you is when he runs he's going to
run his demo oh you think he's going to
run
do i think he's going to run wow okay
how old am i right now 42
42 how long of a bet you want to make
you want to make a ten thousand dollar
million-dollar bed
me a 10-year million-dollar bed i'm not
betting i just want to know this guy's
going to run in the next 10 or 20 years
and he's going to take a note guys
circle back in 20 years he'll be 42.
well let me let me tell you this listen
there are certain guys
there's certain things that you just see
he he's the kind of guy
anything he touches is going to turn to
gold anything
he touches turns to gold that's the rock
he went to
wrestling wrestling he became the face
and you know they were trying to make
him the bad guy and he came out he says
i'm not playing the bad guy
i'm only playing the good guy the other
night we're sitting here doing the lego
where is the lego by the way do we put
it apart oh my god the lego
did it break or no no we have to show it
but somehow we got to show it about that
i don't
by the way you can't carry it only kai
can't carry it okay so we sat here
you just got sat down sam we sat here
trying to
uh what do you call it break the world
record this is pretty easy
so we're trying to beat the world record
right on um tom we were so close
so so the record for this is by four
scientists out of germany yeah
they did it in two hours 51 minutes and
47 seconds
okay how many piece legos 7 500 pieces
it's really it's the biggest thing you
have as many people as you want
yeah no it's only four shout out to your
friend kathy yes gosh got these dudes
that's right you said it good
but you know how long it took us to do
it we didn't three hours we didn't do it
oh yeah
three hours yeah yeah time yeah we
didn't do it in three hours
okay check this out look at this bring
it in bring it in bring it in go ahead
kai where are you going
bring it in right here just put it right
here oh
my gosh my dreams watch out watch out
buddy okay
this right here took us this is kai
ladies so again this is kai
ladies and gentlemen the world record is
two hours 51 minutes and 47 seconds
jesus okay this thing took us not four
hours
not five hours not six hours not seven
hours i don't believe you'd put more
than
a couple hours into it well for me i had
i was i was in and
i was in an hour i went to dinner
it got to the point where we sat there
and said guys i mean at this point the
people are going crazy
adam's knocked out right i'm i am so we
watch a movie
and we watch man on fire you ever seen
man on fire have you seen man on fire
have you seen manafort eric you've seen
man of course is it a romantic comedy
it's
it's not a romantic comedy so you
haven't seen it so man
on fire is with denzel washington i
think it's dakota fanning in it and a
few other people right
who's the bad guy in the movie who ends
up being the bad guy mark anthony
compromises his own daughter to get a
you know uh 10 million dollar check or
something like that right and i said
why would you even play that part right
why would you even say yes to that role
why would you do that right the rock
said i'm not playing the bad guy
i'm a good guy i'm a hero that's who i
am that's his identity
this is who i am he goes plays it does
movies crushes it in movies does all
this stuff that comes out with tequila
at the end of the day the only thing
that's going to be left for this guy's
one thing totally to be the president
that's what i agree because he takes
over he when he goes into something
he's not content being great he has to
be the best so there was nothing left
for him to
accomplish in wrestling nothing he was
the best and he couldn't top it and then
what more can he do in acting i mean
there is such a gap between him and
anything else he's not going to own a
studio
he doesn't want to be a producer he's
laying the groundwork for some sort of
run he has no
question about it why wouldn't he do it
and i think he's doing it from the heart
i think he really thinks that he could
do a good job does he have your vote tom
is he running officially i don't know i
don't know democrat thomas
i'm going to keep everybody in suspense
by saying i'm not sure yet here here's
what i
just want to point out i just want the
audience to realize what just happened
pat started with the rock
shifted gears brought up the lego piece
brought up to star wars brought up man
on fire mark anthony and tied it
all together into why the rock would not
play the bag that was masterful i want
you to know that because i was like
where is he going with the star trek and
star wars i have to give a shout out on
how incredible you did it i'm just
saying
yeah 99 of this is this part right here
this one little tiny part that was me
it took me 15 hours to put this together
we learned a lot about you doing this
lego oh good by the way adam spend one
hour just color coordinating
one of the bags one bag color
coordinating hey by the way i was the
setup guy do you what do you think he's
gonna do with the xfl
can he actually turn that into a success
because he's involved he probably can
i think he could yeah i think he could i
think
can we reveal how long this this thing
took to no no no by the way the video is
coming out here soon and we're gonna i'm
gonna probably give away five of these
if uh
uh uh when the video comes out you have
to see the whole thing i don't wanna
give the time
on how long it took us well just but it
took us a minute all i can say is
we did not break the record no you have
to not break the record i had to cancel
all my weekend plans
literally to build this so for the rest
of you that are watching this
do you think he will run and do you
think he will win
the rock do you think he will run and do
you think he will win let me give a
shout out to a couple people
that uh uh gave uh some here let me pull
this up pictures let me see i thought i
just saw a couple people say a few
things
yeah we had uh i'm a podcaster out of
new york love the telethon id and would
be happy to help
uh this is cafeto break what you talk
about telethon for the small businesses
great to hear that
maybe email us so we keep that on the
list with you in case if we do that
jillian said to sharia said y'all should
address the viral video proven voter
fraud in georgia
kai have you seen a viral viral video
voter fraud in georgia
what are your thoughts on the voter
fraud love the show
tom jillian do not touch that and then
we had another person said adam i will
kill you
michael mintz wants to know where the
hell is the soyboy mafia shirts
where is it where is it people are
asking for it so we got to make sure you
work on that eric's on it
we got to work on that we got to get an
update on that okay i don't want to
break this
guy are you ready to take it back yeah
take it any final thoughts on this
millennium falcons
i'm getting emotional just looking lunch
dinner pat went out to dinner it came
back
mario i didn't came in here
this is the mvp right here kai kai was
the mvp hands down
i was the lvp i was there for i said you
know i kept it
i set my expectations what is that on
the back is that set up like that or is
it breaking it no no no no no no
it is like that by the way do you know
that if you do set a guinness book a
world record you have to spend like 550
bucks or
600 just to get into the book the reason
i know this is because i tried to do it
shonda has not let me live it down she
goes hey what happened to that 500 bucks
how'd that go because i wanted to set a
guinness book a world record with my
radio partner when we had a radio show
we go let's set the record for talking
the longest uninterrupted
so we looked it up and we were going to
do it for a radio gimmick i paid the
money
600 bucks or something in 2003. we paid
8 grand
because we had to have a what did they
call it adjudicator what would there be
oh yeah yeah yeah
we have paid eight grand in reno we
broke the world record for the most
checkers players in one room we have it
outside
we're in the book that is awesome i mean
seriously if you go up front today
yeah when you're leaving go to the front
on the wall you see a guinness book
can you go grab that thing and bring
great stunts all the way in the front
on the wall the the the trophy they gave
us for breaking against us because that
validates it man if you're in the book
you did it well we try to do with the
lego we
definitely felt miserably the the record
was not broken did you win the record
though oh man we did not
the the record was definitely spent the
money though i had to spend the money
all right let's talk about that
let's talk about that let's talk about
the vaccine shot folks question for you
so they're now coming up with an idea
they're scared that a lot of people want
to take the vaccine
you saw president bush obama and clinton
came out and said we'll take the shot
on national tv and then you say ivanka
trump
came out and said she would also do it
on national tv to get people to want to
take the vaccine
and then this comes out would you be
willing to take a covet vaccine in
exchange for 1500
stimulus check americans are eager for
one-time stimulus checks while the u.s
government is working to get coveted
vaccine
vaccinations to the american public now
one proposal from former congressman
john delaney aims to help both sides by
providing stimulus checks in exchange
for getting vaccinated
the goal a reach to 75
vaccination rate faster which could save
both lives and the us economy sending
americans 1500
in exchange for vaccinations could cost
380 billion dollars which delaney admits
is a lot of money
in comparison the first stimulus check
sent by governments this far so
has been 270 billion dollars however
trying
stimulus checks on to vaccinations would
actually be
the most effective strategy here you go
we broke a guinness book of world
seriously nice job this was six years
ago in reno nevada when we broke the
ruckus checkers how many was playing
i don't remember the hundreds it was
hundreds yeah it wasn't it wasn't that
big of a number that record can last
like if somebody wants to break the
record this game needs to be broken
but we did get this and we're in the
book and they did a video on it which
was kind of cool
so going back to it adam
yes sir tom government gives you 1500
bucks
you're gonna take the shot how soon do i
have to make a decision
right now i'm in okay so you're in i'm
in sarcastic
not sarcastic at all you're in yeah you
what the hell do the two things have to
do with each other i'll make up my own
mind if i want the shot you don't have
to pay me
keep your separate good i'm okay fair
enough kai 1500 bucks are you taking it
pro so what's your what's your split
what's the not
20 or is it no it'd be a time
sake like if if i could take it a year
from now and i could kind of see it no
today
i'm saying today yeah no kyle
is the 15 attack no it's to you no taxes
no taxes
vaccine you would think about it
you think about it would you take it
would you take it i'm already
gonna have to take it so i might as well
get some for you guys
i shouldn't ask him if if obama's taking
it if bush is taking it
let's just take care of you ivana
trump's taking it ivanka
this is this is this is trump's doing
you know we've got to give trump credit
for making it we're going to take this
on tv and all this other stuff
how the hell do we know the difference
between the shot and the placebo we know
nothing on on the shots and the placebo
so i don't put a lot of weight and i'm
like they're going to fail
you think they're going by the way just
so you know there's no way
i'm having the president if i'm the
government allowing the three presidents
to take the real vaccine shot on
national television
i would never let that happen if i'm the
u.s government ever really
and if i'm running it i would never what
are you talking about there's a small
percentage of uh
reactions to i would never make that
kind of a reckless decision you know
today
the first shots started yeah
hey can i ask you a question going down
did they do this with polio
with measles do they have to bribe
people to take it i mean this is crazy
by the way if you're watching this
thumbs up
yes i would take your thumbs down hell
no i'm not taking it with the 1500 bucks
smash the thumbs up if you say i'm
looking at it right now we got 440
thumbs up we got 16 thumbs down smash
thumbs up if you would take it for 1500
bucks
smash thumbs down if the 1500 bucks
wouldn't make any difference for you
this thing makes me sick to be honest
with you because everything is
politicized now there isn't one part of
your life
that isn't politicized sports
entertainment
culture going out to dinner there isn't
one aspect of your life
you can't escape it anyway and now the
government is involved in paying you
to take a shot this makes no sense and
who are you delaney
what i've never heard of you why are you
you ran for president i know we dare you
and i never heard of him
you know who he looks like do you ever
see princess bride in vegas vacation
kai pull up the comparison shot there
he's got it i told you who he looks like
he looks
just like john delaney wallace shawn the
guy that was the blackjack dealer in
vegas
vacation changing 500 that guy when you
see him you'll know what i'm talking
about that's
john delaney you just did john delaney
i did it man look at delaney princess
bride that guy killed it
you tell me that's not him that that
looked like him
but that does kind of look like it yeah
go to the other one yeah i want to take
advice from him yeah no thank you
okay i can see some of that anyway so
seriously what do they have to do with
each other
look you don't hey obviously this hasn't
passed yet b
you could say look i'm good i don't need
to do this but if you were gonna
take the vaccine anyway and they're
gonna give you 1500 bucks
you just won the jackpot there it is i
mean
not a bad show you don't get the
stimulus if you don't take the shot is
that what this proposal is
no no no no no you're getting insane
he's saying as a one-time stimulus check
i'm gonna give you 1500 bucks
to take it uh uh henry leonardo just
gave five bucks and it says it's all
crap
i think he wanted to say crap those
presidents are politicians who's all
crabs
tell you that uh they're taking a real
thing i'd only take it because i'm
uh i travel that's what he said okay i
don't think you know good point if
they're gonna prevent you from not being
able to travel
you know you would take it you know what
can i make one quick point i think the
masks
really help preventing colds
i've gotten cold i wear a mask every day
i think there is some benefit to wearing
the mask
hold especially if you travel a lot i i
just a random thought
i thought you were an anti-massacre i'm
not the anti-massacre i mean we're in a
pandemic i think it makes sense to wear
the mask without a doubt
tom i'm not like where you're flipping
on me well look i'm a good test case
you're because
you're like i don't even know who you
are anymore i thought you were this
right-wing extremist like unreasonable
like now you're this mass guy you're
you're sleeping in airbnbs you're
like take it from here adam i can't even
do this anymore
tom i don't know who you are anymore
buddy shonda is rubbing off on you
that's what's going on
kind i think there's some benefit to it
ladies and gentlemen tom
just came out and said mask work this is
amazing this is
on so can we talk about a couple things
that just came up with
uh let's let's stay on that miami thing
because silicon valley elites are moving
to miami but vc's told the mayor that a
state law needs to change
before they would relocate so we talked
about earlier companies from new york
relocating to miami right we're talking
about goldman sachs carl icahn some of
those guys right
and one of them moved into uh uh palm
beach the 41 billion dollar
uh uh uh hedge fund what's his name uh
uh
carl paul no no paul singer 41 billion
dollars moving his stuff to
uh palm beach but here's an issue with
miami and miami mayor you've interviewed
you've been a vietnam veteran mayor
francis suarez yeah the mayor of miami
spent at least
uh at least part of the weekend on
twitter trying to convince silicon
valley tech workers
and investors to hang up their fleece
vests and move to south florida's
uh a growing tech hub tex migration to
miami has been happening for a while now
that while reddit co-founder alexis
ohanian making the move to south florida
a few years ago
but it's picked up steam as more people
work from home particularly during the
pandemic
but even as tech investors depart from
miami full on migration hinges on the
city's ability to track top companies
talents
and candidates might not come as long as
state allows companies to use
non-compete
agreements a non-compete is part of an
employment contract where the worker
agrees
they won't take a job as a competitor
and start a rival business for some time
after leaving the company so there's an
issue with that in florida yeah of
course for non-compete agreements yeah
do they have that in texas
they uh in texas no you're fine in texas
but in california is an issue
it's not a non-compete right non-compete
is a uh
doesn't have a lot of weight in
california in california no but it
doesn't matter miami it's huge
or florida it's huge yeah that's that's
the point yeah the whole point of the
story right so these guys are talking
about that's kind of hurting us you know
all this other stuff so what do you know
about it i know you were just talking to
his campaign trying to get uh mayor
francis suarez
uh on the phone this morning he was busy
but i was speaking with his
communications
department he we can get him on when
when we'd like
um a couple different things going on
here number one was the
miami was the number one top city for
small business in 2019
so they've laid the groundwork for being
very small business friendly very
entrepreneur friendly low taxes
you know sunny weather all that going on
mayor francis suarez is leading the
the charge on this um for someone who's
lived and worked in miami i can tell you
the non-compete is a very big deal like
it's i thought that there was sort of a
universal thing
but this is a very florida-centric
policy apparently
and that's something that's going to
have to be rectified if all these
bigwigs and silicon valley type
people are considering moving to florida
and specifically south florida no one's
moving to the panhand
panhandle um but in that tweet i don't
know if we want to pull that up kai if
you have that
he said let's talk let's talk about this
so he's opening this i mean if there's
somebody who is
business friendly entrepreneurial driven
and
willing to make it to will and deal and
make business happen it's this guy right
here
francis suarez shout out to you francis
um he said how can i help
um dm me he's sliding his dm i'd be
happy to dm me and we'll set it up
so i did not know that this was such a
non-big deal in california it is a big
deal in florida
everyone who's considering moving jobs
asks about and now compete
but in california i guess you can just
kind of come and go as you please we'll
see what they can do
i read some of this threat it's
interesting he really does interact with
these tech people in silicon valley a
couple things number one
if you're super rich at some point you
want to have some fun there is no fun to
be had in silicon valley these guys want
to get the hell out of there they want
the hot chicks
they want to have fun i think that
drives a lot of this i think they're
bored
the other thing is how can not some of
these engineers and really smart tech
people in silicon valley
be a little bit more on the conservative
side than these radical lefts that are
running the
the social media giants out there i mean
at some point you can't agree with
everything that that company does and
you want to fresh start somewhere else
third thing is if there is a serious
issue with the non-compete in florida
ron desantis will fix it i mean that has
a smart governor
he's five steps ahead of everybody else
if it means more business for the state
of florida and in this case
a lot more and a lot more revenue he'll
change it watch for that to be changed
in a couple
years yeah i wouldn't be surprised
either by the way he's a guy that's also
wanting to run
in the future he's a guy that's very
ambitious to want to run for office
yeah and he's already said i will never
do a lockdown he's already put forth
legislation that will
make it a huge felony to riot anywhere
in florida as well so look what's
happening right now i've been saying
this now for a while if california and
texas had a baby
the baby's name would be what florida
it's that simple
you take the best of california you take
the best of texas
you combine it to get you got florida if
i was the governor of florida if i was
the governor of florida
i would out recruit the governor of
texas
like never before if i was the governor
of florida i would out recruit
i'm surprised that florida doesn't out
recruit
texas i am so surprised that florida
doesn't out recruit texas to get the
businesses to move to florida they have
more to offer than texas does when you
think i know a lot of people disagree
with this
but between those two states you got the
top two states competing
nevada's kind of tough yeah nevada's
kind of tough to be recruiting to nevada
i get that it's a good place to be a lot
of californians are going there
but i think florida is going to be
especially with what's going on right
now a lot of these guys going for
because typically california when they
leave they go where they go nevada
or they go to texas yep new york city
exactly or arizona
but now cal aloha ohanian is going from
silicon valley think about where silicon
valley is
all the way to the complete corner
that's where they're going they're
changing corners from one end to the
other
side of the east coast yeah exactly
welcome do you think
i mean these guys are smart desantis is
smart so is abbott these are smart
governors that know what they're doing
do you think there's a little bit of
them they're thinking
if i recruit too much it could flip my
state a little bit i mean if you look at
arizona
the influx of californians into arizona
has had an impact on how that state
voted but that's a different recruiting
that's a different recruiting than it is
for recruiting like nevada
and recruiting like uh uh like i was
thinking about going to arizona for a
long time so i went to phoenix okay
we went and looked at homes in phoenix
there was a place i don't know what it's
called it's a paradise valley paradise
i talked about it right no but i knew
that's where you don't communicate it's
the only place you
we went to this place and by the way no
i mean it's like a beautiful place
you go to this community you're gonna
get a home for like four million dollars
okay but you get the home for four
million dollars
they go pick up your groceries for you
you simply call the concierge
you live in a community they go pick up
your groceries for you they have a spa
in the community
they have massages in the community they
have everything in the community so you
and then you have your own house gated
community gated house in a gated
community the place was beautiful
and then i came back and said why would
i go to phoenix what for
what am i going to go there for if i'm a
golfer i get it
if i got someone i get it but if i have
a choice between them and nevada why
would i go phoenix over going to nevada
i'm not going to have to pay the tax if
i go to taxes if i go to nevada so
so what phoenix is attracting is
different
than what nevada's attracting phoenix is
attracting middle america
because it's cheaper to go there let me
go there what nevada attracted
is business owners by the way the whole
tony shea story like zappos went there
and you know his move was to move zappos
to headquarters being there a lot of
other businesses moved to nevada because
of taxes
this is different phoenix is very
different than nevada texas and
florida quick shout out chris puckett
donated five bucks he says i've worked
for google
facebook and yahoo couldn't have done
that with uh
with a ridiculous non-compete silicon
valley would not exist without this so
to eliminate the non-compete exactly i'm
saying it wouldn't it wouldn't happen
you know those
those governors have to be like big time
football coaches the way they recruit
man just all-out warfare just go for it
good analogy i
actually agree with tom you've used the
word recruit recruit recruit
i mean that's what you do in your
business but i've never really heard
governor's recruiting until i started
you know
hearing you say it so often so i was in
the state of california
rick perry was coming to california
recruiting businesses rick perry got on
the radio saying
if you run a business in the state of
california yeah and you're sick of the
politics you're sick of the regulation
you're sick of the taxes
call me at this number did that really
yeah
are you kidding well he then we met with
him yeah
we sat down with perry he took us to
rangers game we spent a whole day with
him we spent with time with him and
nolan ryan and don nelson
don nelson's son donnie nelson yeah we
sat in the box
and perry sat down with my with my wife
jen and talked to him and nolan ryan
jennifer used to play
softball with nolan ryan's daughter so
next thing you know we're sitting there
having a conversation together
then we met with mayor maso of frisco
who was the
the frisco was the fastest growing city
in america it was a three-term
mayor i think he was there for like
eight or twelve years crushing nine
years right
cowboys have their physics that's right
that's right that's right yeah and then
pga moved to frisco by the way pg
headquarters is officially in on frisco
and then we're like wait a minute this
guy is a and then when you come here
to visit texas you should have seen how
they treated you they got gifts for our
kids
they knew our kids names every single
thing was detailed
the way they recruited us to the state
of texas it was
beautifully done i think florida's
missing an opportunity
i don't know florida wants all the
businesses to go there
but if they did florida should have 10
more fortune 500 headquarters over there
than they do right now why would you say
that florida wouldn't want the best i
don't know i don't know it's a purple
state why wouldn't you want more people
to want to go there yeah
but i think the emphasis has got to be
on recruiting talent by the way
you know why florida would also be a
great here's what i would focus on if i
was a governor of florida
i would focus on businesses fortune 500
businesses that do a lot of business
with
europe and international well latin
america that's the gateway to latin
america so well what i'm saying is
europe europe specifically there's a big
difference between being
in dallas to go to london yes then it is
to go from fort lauderdale to go to
london right
that's why you in new york city you go
to where london boom easy flight right
laguardia or john
you know any of those airports you're
going over there okay florida has that
opportunity those types of fortune 500
companies
are moving to florida easy boom take a
flight here in europe why wouldn't you
do that so
anyways i think florida's got a big
opportunity for recruiting
uh uh if they capitalize on it but we'll
see what's going on we've got
pat here's an idea we've got to look
into this florida thing
just we've got to look into florida it
sounds like a nice place there's a
possibility of moving yeah yeah
we got to look into that i would
consider it yeah uh
very very seriously yeah considering we
should look into that i got to contact
you i know the challenge with you is the
one challenge we have with you is
we were talking about this this weekend
adam for whatever reason
is in love with the nightclubs and uh
adam is like the the
only place and the dirty brunette i
cannot believe the gecko
the gecko weddings you guys want to win
the gecko shout out to the cafe gecko
and you know
yeah at the at the millionaire club or
something when some of these private
jets land that's where you need to be
partying
no we'll we'll you can see me at bodega
or club live in miami that's about it
all right so let's think there's an age
limit when you no longer want to go to
nightclubs i've hit it
going towards you you hit that like 15
years ago well i'm older than you so i
probably did hit it 15 years ago
where the thought of going to a
nightclub is just like too much work
adam's the other way around the thought
of not going to the nine o'clock god i'm
miserable
i don't get to a nightclub in the next
adam's here seven days a week is that a
freak out i'm gonna freak out
adam just likes the idea of walking up
with that gate the velvet rope opening
for him
did you say walk in with the with the
hungarian
no he needs a special code word to get
into this party uh
you know you know how you you know how
you're if you're south beach royalty if
you could walk up and you could be like
hey look at these 25 hungarian guys
they're with me they're going to come
they're going to adam came in and they
come in the club
if you can get a bunch of dudes in the
club adam asked me if you spell orgy
with a y
or an i.e i had to correct him on that
wasn't sure so
but tom knew
tom tried to set me up buddy oh yeah you
wrote that story all right all right
so let's go and be more excited let's go
and by the way pull up aoc sweater we
got we got to get this to people
you guys got to order this sweater you
guys got to order this sweater
i mean here's aoc saying tax the rich
selling a
18 sweater for 58
talk about hypocrisy do you see this let
me get this straight
so you say tax to rich this sweater no
joke
yeah this sweater is a 18 sweater it's
the cheapest sweater you can potentially
put on your
shopify store to sell and she's selling
it for
58 bucks tax the rich
you think the low income middle america
is going to go out there and buy a
58 sweater kai it's also sold out if you
look
all of them are sold out but the point
i'm trying to make to is the following
her community is supporting a 58
sweater i have an idea tell me i have an
idea we come out with a sweater
vt logo on the bottom it says tax the
[ __ ] they know
they know who it means they tax the
[ __ ]
valuetainment and um oh what would we
charge for that sweater by the way 12
bucks 58 bucks let's see let's see who
uh
i'd like to know we should put 57.99 we
should be saying
that's undercut does anything scream
democracy more than this
she's selling a t-shirt she's branding
her a sweatshirt she's branding it with
her initials for god's sake
and she's i'd like to see that debate
that you're putting together i know
you're working on this i
i would easily be working on a debate
can you reveal it do you want to review
it i would love if
should i reveal it you want to review if
people want to go on twitter and say
this
i would see if the audience would be
down for this so pat how many guys would
like to see
a debate between aoc and candace owens
imagine a debate between aoc and candace
owns okay
and we do with pay-per-view style aoc
candace owens they debate on the stage
90 minutes okay and there's a moderator
and they go maybe maybe it's got to be
more than nine but i think it's going to
be like two hour debate
well there's a round two yeah round one
round two potentially in the uh
when we have others a ask questions
i would be willing to pay both candice
owens
and aoc each a hundred thousand dollars
if they're willing to do that debate
i'll pay each 100 000
if they want to do that debate i have a
feeling candace owens would do it
without a
you know even thinking about it yeah but
i have a feeling aoc would turn it down
i also think after the debate yeah after
the debate
in the nate robinson jake paul
logan paul oh you have some ideas with
that logan paul
and floyd mayor i think they they
straight up fist fight afterwards they
get but we have him in the ring
yeah byron dell had had an idea they
want you to reveal it though
i don't know i don't know i'm gonna
throw byron under the bus here here you
go buddy
maybe they do some mud wrestling
afterwards so that's just an idea that
our good friends put out there to still
a thing
we're going to make it a thing we're
going to make mud wrestling great again
that's what we're going to do tom here
on
valuetainment but you know look we have
like it's a it's like a
who would like to see that yeah who
would actually like to see that uh
debates
fights hundred thousand actually aoc
knows she would be exposed she would be
dressed down and destroyed
who's your favorite who's the favorite
let me ask you oh it's not even a
question but here's oh you think candace
is the favorite
okay by the way if you're watching this
if candace owens debates aoc who wins
the debate oh i'm talking about the
fight
oh my wrestling no that's a different
story i think aos
yeah that's a different story from the
streets yeah so candace owens aoc who
wins the debate
well you got to go round per round right
so who wants a debate tell me who wins
it i think candice owens probably has a
better
um message right better message but who
do you think wins
i think look i think that's going to be
pretty even stephen i think
really i think i think wow i think it's
can you order that shirt for him
order that sweater for soyboy mafia and
aoc collab coming your way
yeah i think if you did but i think aoc
would win the actual
guys thumbs up candace owens wins thumbs
down aoc wins
thumbs up candace owens thumbs down aoc
the biggest problem you'd have if this
was a two hour event that valuetainment
was hosting what are you gonna do for
the other hour and 59
after aoc taps out after one minute she
would want
nothing to do with candace oh and she
would run and hide but she could
sell her sweatshirt she could wear that
you know think the sales
be a good marketing branding idea for
her come on the valuetainment
debate the question is what would it
take for him
i'll buy sweaters that says tax to rich
texas did you see what candace owen who
was it rihanna this guy collab
connections put ten bucks i'll buy both
sweaters tax the [ __ ] and tax the rich
for 58 bucks each
to watch the debate nice p p i i think
we could pull this off i just don't
think aoc would do the debate
i don't either i i don't think she'll
sell sweaters but won't do a debate
no i don't think she would where do you
see aoc in the next 10 years running
el presidente oh yeah we need rock
yeah to beat her in the primary this is
rock and aoc run together he's the
president she's the
vice president there's a man that would
never he would never does america vote
for that he would never do that why do
you say that because he's not
politically on the same side as aoc is
but that's why he's bringing her for a
big tent
yeah but he he would he would not he
would not go with that uh uh anyways
so let's let's skip through this by the
way
uh oh some people said they think aoc
would win the debate
surprisingly so a lot of people said aoc
would win the debate oh these little
interesting entertainment yeah this is
interesting a lot of people are putting
uh saying aoc would pull it off over
candace owens okay uh
oh interesting uh i'd love to see that
debate
again i gave my offer i'm probably gonna
go tweet it on again on twitter as well
and if anybody wants to retweet it i'd
love to see that happen i think it'd be
pay-per-view type of stuff and
we can even do profit sharing for both
of them nice literally whatever we sell
we would do profit sharing as well i'm
very open to like a real socialist idea
i would actually share the money i would
actually do a socialist idea
yeah we would do profit and snoop
retweets you you better tag pat
oh we would have a snoop as a
commentator snoop a loop
bring your green hat so so by the way
logan paul and mayweather said they're
going to fight each other
snoop says i'm ready hopefully who's
winning that fight who's winning that
fight what do you mean who's winning
that fight
oh my god look let me put it logan paul
is 60 pounds bigger than that
let me tell you another crazy prediction
here logan paul
is one they're gonna run for office
unbelievable logan paul
is for people who underestimate a guy
like logan paul
you do not underestimate guys like that
the guy is brilliant
and he's learning and he's young and
he's
how old is he he's got to pull that off
to mid to late 20s he's he's
attractive his personality is attractive
he's not afraid
he likes to heed he likes you know he
can get in there i think the guy's got a
big upside in his life 25 years old yeah
this guy's got a big upside
brother jake is a little bit more not
not at his level no it's different
personalities
jake's little too chippy logan to me is
a little bit more composed you're a fan
but you know what i think
i'm i'm a fan of any here's a mother
that raises these two boys to do what
they're doing for some props to the mom
to be able to
the other day logan was celebrating
seeing his brother knocking out uh
robinson i like seeing that i like those
stories yeah
but i think that i think this guy's got
a big upside in life a very big upside
aokai lunch why is that i bet on nate
i thought nate robbins is going to win
too i think jake can really fight i
think that was impressive
there tom goes again agree with you you
know what he warned nate robinson he
says do not let your children watch this
please i'm begging you do not let them
watch their daddy be embarrassed he was
saying that before the fight he was
legit
you know if you look at the social media
followers of logan i mean he's got four
youtube channels
one with 20 million plus one with five
million plus one okay so
you know these guys there's an end game
to this because making these videos is
hard work every day
and by the way he's doing it with the
vlog vlog is not easy yeah here's the
other thing when you think about the
poll that these guys have
they grew up in ohio they grew up in
cleveland moved here jake paul was
originally on a disney show he tried to
be a legit actor
then he was making so much money on
social media so
dash probably three four years ago was
watching jake paul
youtube videos until we kind of saw him
and said he had enough of this but he
thought jake paul was the man
right so we found out where jake paul
lived in west hollywood he lived right
behind
fred siegel's so we went over there we
would go to his house there was a crowd
there
every day just just to see i mean
tourists from all over rivaling
hollywood boulevard
fans a couple times he'd come out and
people would go
absolutely bananas 24 hours a day
seven days a week camped out at his
house security
the whole thing and people from all over
the world these guys have an incredible
pull
but this this whole thing just look at
the marketing behind this the
pay-per-view numbers that they're going
to get is going to be insane with his
ability
to promote to his youtube audience and
the other thing i think is i think floyd
mayweather will injure him if he wants
to
i mean he has no idea what taking a
floyd mayweather punch is going to be
like
in your face he'll hit him 10 times in
the face before uh logan paul even
throws a punch
who will mayweather mayweather they're
not in the same league but
white weather is one of the top 10
boxers of all time yeah he thinks he's
the greatest of all time
i also think this is the future of
boxing there's no personalities in real
boxing look at it we have to recycle
mike tyson
and roy jones jr to get any sort of
paperwork be honest did we not have fun
that night i mean it was
seriously that was that's the point a
pathetic fight we watched i mean
jones tyson jones but we had a great
time that night
uh that was such a sham that they called
it a uh draw
yeah i saved the lunch that was vegas
though that was all vegan
you know what it's gonna be tyson and
hollyfield next yeah i saw that by the
way
meyer davidoff just gave a hundred
dollars saying invictus pharmacy loves
to listen to
pat's podcast and valuetainment keep it
up fellas thank you meyer
pharmacy invictus pharmacy there you go
there you go
by the way just so you know adam's ready
to take the vaccine shot for 1500 bucks
is ready so let's let's talk about
something serious let's talk about some
series so
uh john ratcliffe which i'm sure you
know who john ratcliffe is he's
uh on the trump's administration you
know talking about uh
you know uh security and what's going on
with china he writes this article okay
can you put that article up he writes
this five days ago on wall street
journal okay
five days ago he writes this on wall
street journal if you got it up just put
it okay just go on google
type in radcliffe wsj type in john
ratcliffe
rat uh wsj okay it's with a t
but that works that uh it's rat
cliff rat cliff yeah t
right click and then put china put also
china in the in the title but china
there you go you might not be able to
uh okay then maybe it's not that easy to
find go to the one i sent you
there it was right there article comes
out talking about
what china is working on okay and when
you
when you go through this it's pretty
epic on what he explains
i sent you two links kai for you to pull
up okay before you guys pull this up
i'm going to ask you before you guys see
this here i want to ask you
what do you think is the biggest enemy
to us
the next five to 10 years what country
is the number one enemy to us in the
next five to ten years
what do you think do you think it's
china do you also agree with that i
think we're our own worst enemy number
one but then as far as a foreign enemy
it's china okay who's after china
who's after china as far as defense or
for his competition
give me any of it give me any of it
russia's up there russia's up there for
what defense or economy
no uh defense defense russia outside of
north korea just because of the psycho
okay so recklessness is where you put up
there okay
so what do you think russia ranks
in world economy gdp once not in the top
50.
maybe maybe not maybe not in the top 20.
not the top 20s
what do you think russia are like nine
they're number 11. russia's number 11.
okay
do you have the link i sent you kai okay
go to that one right there go to that
one right there watch this here
so this is the top gdps worldwide okay
this is from investopedia so it's not
just any
opinion u.s is number one at us nominal
gdp is 2.21.44
trillion and the gdp is the same right
but look at china where china's at next
their gdp is 27.31
trillion dollars coming up china's
experience has
experienced exponential growth over the
past few decades breaking the barriers
of a century plan close economy
to evolve into a manufacturing exporting
hub of the world china is often referred
to as the world
worlds factory given its huge
manufacturing
and they're projected to get their you
know the way the numbers are going right
now to pass up u.s
in the next handful of years okay
they've already passed up in
gdp not nominal nominal gdp us's ahead
and then go to number three then you got
japan
then you got germany keep going down
then you got india
who's coming up aggressively then you
got uk then you got france
then you have italy then you have brazil
and then you have canada
you do not see what russia in the top 10
russia's number 10
4.21 number 11 4.21 trillion
canada is ahead it's unbelievable that's
unbelievable california's way ahead
that's the point
canada is ahead of russia if you would
have said that to somebody they would
say what are you talking about
now watch with china do you know who has
the largest navy in the world right now
china do who has the largest army in the
world right now
china do you know what china is doing
right now with their military with their
soldiers
they're putting jeans they're putting uh
uh what do you call it
uh they're they're testing their
soldiers to become super soldiers
china's doing that
so not just steroids not just steroids
they're testing their soldiers they're
putting additional stuff into their
soldiers
for them to become it's like gene
testing they're doing with their
soldiers for their soldiers to become
super soldiers
china's doing this now watch what
happens
yesterday tucker does a show talking
about a video that went viral
that was given by a professor of china
and he's given a message in china he's
given this message in china
china immediately take this video down
but before they take the video down
u.s gets a hold of it and they translate
what the speaker had to say
first of all pull up pull up the speaker
pull up the video of his
let me first explain who he is go back
to uh
uh introducing who he is so what is that
9 13
go all the way to the beginning go all
the way to the beginning
here's who he is don shank
is the vice dean of the school of
international relations
renmin university of china vice director
and secretary of the center for foreign
strategic studies of china
this talk was given what um maybe a week
and a half ago
okay say 10 days ago can you go to the
part that you want to say
and maybe first put the speed at 1.25
because he talks a little bit slow
okay then keep it at 1.0 just stay with
me here and try to read below because
he's not speaking in english
adam try to stay here on the bottom if
you guys want i can read it for you
but we'll go through this here together
look what he says matter of fact i want
to read it so everybody can see it
you can put it on the audio that's fine
hey i just this guy
by the way he's becoming the next tai
lopez of media every every time you
watch
something he comes up okay just try to
read it because it's tough if i read it
and
go back a little bit kai did you put it
on 1.0 what speed do you have it on
leave it at 1.0 no no one it's too much
go
okay go ahead
um
are you kidding me are they doing this
many commercials nowadays on youtube
we've been utilizing the core power
united states
for the last 30 to 40 years since 97
yeah wall street can't fix trump
trump had a default on wall street but i
won't go into the deal
i may not have enough time
another scene brian was elected
by the way guys i'm translating all this
so i'm not reading anything
go back this is not a joke go back pause
it real quick okay this is the one thing
i don't want to i don't want to joke
about on this podcast
it's very very important this part you
guys have to pay attention to what he's
saying
okay but now we're seeing biden was
elected
just read the captions
the traditional lead the political elite
the establishment
has some sort of global foundation have
you noticed that who helped him
hunter biden build the foundations got
it through all these deals and all this
okay pause right there so positive time
who's he talking about
got it who's he talking about dad he
says no no
this is china this is tama china we did
we helped them
okay so watch continue
we use an appropriate way to express
some good will
this is my personal understanding based
on my limited professional background
if we understand the matter for the
perspective of the international
political economy i think there's a
tactical and political value in it
opening the financial markets between
china united states itself
now
don't dump me in that case can you
understand it that way
yeah i understand it the other way
around which has happened
sorry i happen to think that this could
be another explosive theory
i have to think that opening the
financial markets is precisely the sort
of decoupling of the united states
opening up the financial markets and
that's exactly what decomposition
is in a sense why we're giving such a
hard time in many of these
does he get into what i want you to put
up or no
okay so so this is something you have to
watch on your own because
there's a part where he talks about
saying we have people on the inside and
wall street we have people on the inside
on politics he says we have people on
the inside all the way at the top of the
u.s government
china does yeah we have people on the
inside at the top of the us government
china does right
then so whilst then he says trump was a
problem for them
trump got in the way for them trump
didn't help him out but biden's easy to
deal with
biden's going to be easier to deal with
because we're back to being able to do
what we wanted to do all these years
here's the problem let me give you the
problem here he validated
what happened with biden and who helped
him out this guy's validated it
that that took place and
there was relations between biden and
and what he called it
uh china and this one hunter and biden
of course biden and china hunter biden's
not doing anything with china without
joe biden
hunter biden cannot do anything in china
without his father joe biden
and he said that in interviews hunter
biden asked the question but one
one interviewer asked biden a question
saying do you think
you would have been able to get this
board seat without your father hunter
biden's answer this isn't a live
interview you know what he says
probably not without my father hunter
biden said this in an interview okay
where am i going with this here's where
i'm going with this let's just say
china has a million and one different
dirt on biden let's just say they do
let's assume they do let's play that
card if
china has a lot of dirt on biden
if they do how do you negotiate with
biden
you use it against him actually think
about what i just said right there
if china who is growing the way they're
growing right now
and they're about do you need water or
you're good and they're about to be the
number one
gdp economy in the world their military
is
ridiculously grown for the longest time
they kept saying we're not military
we're not military we're not military
now they're investing into their
military they're gene testing their
soldiers
they have the biggest navy okay they're
doing all the stuff that they're doing
over there they're the best at bio
warfare
they're the best at cyber warfare
they're the best at it
they're going in that direction what
happens if china has all the dirt on
biden
so imagine behind closed doors how do
negotiations go how do you negotiate
with them
what do you say simplify what do you say
hey
you know i just want you to know you
know i interviewed this guy from the fbi
what was his name uh uh uh whitehurst is
it whitehurst
okay so this is the only guy in the fbi
that ever sued the fbi and got a 1.4
million auto check the only employee in
the history of fbi that sued the fbi and
president clinton and got a 1.4 million
dollar check in 1993.
he's the only guy that's ever done it
successfully okay and he got ousted
i said the who's the most powerful
person in politics john f kennedy
remember when a question i asked him
john f kennedy
uh uh edgar who j edgar hoover or uh the
mafia he says oh j edgar hoover
he says fbi is the most powerful
organization in america more than the
president that's
really yeah i said how did they do it he
says here's how we do it
he says you're going you just say look
you know
like you know you got to do this you
know
you know you know what i mean you know
don't even have to say it you got to do
this you know what i'm saying so he says
that's all we say and they know and they
have to do exactly what we want them to
do because they know
we know you think china's going to use
that card against biden behind closers
saying hey joe
you know we know so we kind of need you
to
sure do this do you think that's what's
going to happen i think it's already
happening probably with how he's
stacking his cabinet
with a little help from you you have to
keep that part in mind man this is the
kind of stuff because now here's the
other part
you know what's the other part um
how long does it take you to do research
on somebody online who's pretty active
on social media to know which way they
lean politically
how much time not 10 minutes i'm being
serious with everybody here
not long how long will it take you to
research somebody online it could be a
minute could be a minute okay
i agree with you could be a minute okay
fair enough
how much can you learn about anybody if
you know their enemy
i mean you can learn a lot what can you
learn about them how long can you learn
about anybody
if you can learn who their number one
enemy is
i see we're going with this okay so
where am i going with this here's where
i'm going with this
in the next 3 6 12 months you know what
mainstream media
i project predict is going to do here's
what they're going to do
mainstream media is about to sell us
who the real enemy is over the next four
years under biden administration
and i don't think they're going to sell
china for being the number one enemy
i think they're going to make russia the
number one enemy
potentially iran which iran is an enemy
i don't know if their number one enemy
because iran reports to who
to china okay don't forget that
china is bailing out iran china china's
investing into iran which means iran
owes
who china a favor okay china's plain
africa china is playing everybody
right now is what they're doing because
they have money they're playing
everybody right now
media is going to try to sell us that
somebody else is the enemy russia's not
a top 10 economy
russia is not a top 10 economy if you
you just saw the list right there
yeah it's not going to be any of those
guys china
is ahead so far it's not even
funny what they can do today and this is
just
getting started they're just getting
warmed up
the momentum that was going on when
people say why are you
supporting a trump this and trump that i
said dude i don't
support a trump does trump that what i
supported was one thing
i wanted to see how china was going to
react if we went with the sanctions
and the terrorists for four more years i
wanted to see what was going to happen
to iran
if you went with the sanctions and the
terrorists for a couple more years
that's what i wanted to see
because there's one person they couldn't
negotiate with and it was trump
they couldn't buy him out he wasn't he
was the one guy they couldn't buy out
now i hope i'm a hundred percent wrong
i hope i'm 100 wrong i hope i'm 100
wrong about all of this but if i'm not
china is going to make a lot of
advancement the next four years because
they're going to be able to ask
and say hey joe just so you know you
know we know right yes
we need you to put this person on your
administration joe you know we know
right we need this person to get a job
at fbi
hey you know we know right this person
what do you think they know what do i
think they know
yeah what do you mean what do i think
they know if they have done all the
business dealings with china
if they have done all the business
dealings with china the biden family
guess what they know
all the business dealings they did with
china that would have hurt them in the
election
and they can say we will release
everything and ruin your life
and if you don't think we know more we
know everything about your son
you know what happened the other day
facebook got caught did you guys hear
about what facebook got caught with
okay okay just type in on google
facebook camera instagram
you guys hear about this or no yeah a
little bit okay facebook
instagram camera okay facebook
instagram camera okay just this should
be a couple days ago
and go to news go to news
we're looking at fresh i just lost it
from 40 different states
okay a story came out facebook there you
go bloomberg
okay this is not just any side facebook
accused of watching instagram users
through
cameras to learn more about them by the
way this got even deeper in the last few
days
read the story though so facebook is
being sued again
uh for allegedly spying on instagram
users this time through
unauthorized use of their mobile phone
cameras
so think about this you're sitting in
the bathroom you're on your instagram
again you're checking everybody else's
picture they're watching you
while you're you're laying next to your
girl you're laying in bed next to your
girl
and you're on your instagram and you're
showing her a picture they're watching
you
okay you know what they said oh was a
glitch it wasn't it wasn't intentional
was accidental
that this happened okay you know
i used to be the guy that would be like
oh come on guys when people put a
sticker over here on the camera you know
which camera i'm telling everybody would
you you remember when apple back in the
days they would play put the sticker
over there people are watching like dude
are you freaking
out of your mind i'd be the first one to
say what is wrong with you you know
lawsuit bloomberg this is not an opinion
this is lawsuit bloomberg right
okay this stuff is happening a lot of
these conspiracy theories that we
thought were conspiracy theories are now
becoming conspiracy theories they're
becoming factual wow
so if china has access to the best
hackers in the world
what do you think they have on their
cameras
what do they have access on their
cameras do you think they can tap into
hunter biden who's constantly losing his
laptops left and right leaving them
behind
what do you think they have access to
let me tell you when j edgar hoover
would go
and talk to john f kennedy and bobby and
would say hey we just want you to know
this is what we got
and a mafia who had control over hoover
they went to hoover and they said hey we
know you're a cross-dresser because back
in the days that was a big deal for
it's not today's times we're talking
about years ago they say here's what we
know you do j grover if you ever talk
about the mafia we're gonna have a
problem
so back then they played the same game
hoover played against kennedy the mob
played against two hoover
hoover yeah china's about to play that
card against biden if they do
buddy this isn't about you and i anymore
this is about fundamentally
what they're going to try to do to the
idea of america because there are some
china is one of the most competitive
groups of people
and they want to beat the number one
country in the last 150 years
and that's u.s yep and they're all i
want to beat them they're also patient
and they're also strategic
and they also have the media on their
side here because cnn has already come
out and said that they ignored the
hunter biden story
which goes along the lines of i honestly
think and adam's going to jump all over
me again i don't think joe biden wanted
to win this election
personally because i think he's smart
enough to know what's out there
what can be revealed in all this and
that's why i think he'll kind of
fade away but you know the difference
between china and the us
again is we think the our enemy is the
other side
you know the republicans think the enemy
is the left the left thinks the enemy is
the right we spend
50 of our time fighting amongst
ourselves when we should be putting all
our time
into looking what's happening at the
people that really do hate us
and do want to take what we have and do
want to change us and that is going to
be
our undoing and it's starting to happen
and then when you have a complicit media
and a complicit social media and
especially something that can be
manipulated by our real enemies we've
got real problems
um obviously i think joe biden wanted to
win i don't think you'd do all this
to not win um you know ironically you
use joe biden's
go-to quote that we are not the enemies
of each other we need to come together
whether you're on the left or the right
we're all americans that whole thing
blue state red state
clearly china is a major issue clearly
if they truly did and i'm not saying
that they don't i'm i'm asking a
question here if they truly did have
something on him
why would he run meaning he has to know
like as much as you want to say wait
what wait wait wait okay
wait he did something illegal yeah if he
did something then you missed everything
i just said that's not no it's not
obviously i heard everything you missed
everything i just said okay what did i
mention so ask the question again
why would he run why would he run okay
did you just miss everything i just said
no
pat but ask yourself saying that you're
saying that he's a pawn for china
wait a minute if you're saying why would
he run if they know everything you know
because
you're saying he's a pawn for china
because they can tell you
you better run don't worry you will win
look we're at a point right now is it
fair to say that
is it fair to say that you're going
deeper no i'm not going deep with this
is it fair to say at this point in the
game is it fair to say that america has
meddled in a lot of other countries
elections
they say that yes or no they say that
there we can't sit here and be like i'm
not sitting here being naive and a fool
about it
is it talking it's not there is talk
there's proof
okay there's proof that there's been
america's meddled in other countries
elections
okay because america said i think that's
a good the reason why other countries
cannot stand america sometimes is why
power because we've meddled because we
meddled okay do you think russia's
meddled in other people's elections
for sure do you think china's meddled on
other people's elections do you think
iran's meddled in other people's
elections
quite frankly here what are you doing
what do you need
to meddle in other people's elections
actually what ability do you need it's
one ability what is the information
information propaganda and hackers yeah
you need you need proper hackers and
proper digital marketing guys these days
yeah i mean prior to you know 2000 that
was not but there was a different method
of doing it back then today it's
a lot easier today you need some 22 year
old kids who understand facebook codes
you need some
guys who are 18 year old kids behind
closers who know how to hack into the
pentagon system it's not that
complicated for these guys it's very
easy for them
very easy you know how you play
basketball in the effortless and all the
stuff you do it's very easy for them
effortless they can hack into any system
they want
it's easy for them so when you say if
this is the case why would biden want to
run you miss everything i just said
they would want if you if you're trying
to think like china think like the enemy
actually think like the enemy let's
think like the enemy
you're china it's 2018.
this crazy competitive guy who's not
afraid of you
says i'm putting tariffs on you
this this guy that says if you don't do
xyz i'm putting sanctions
this guy out of nowhere comes out and
says wait a minute
you had huawei cfo daughter in canada
doing deals with iran and i told you not
to do business with anyone
with what do you call it iran why would
you decide to do that the cfo the
daughter she gets arrested no problem
sanctions on huawei sanctions on china
sanctions on iran
and if anybody does business with iran
you can't do anything with u.s
22 countries or give or take say iran we
can't do any business with you
iran takes a massive gas prices go up
the government of iran says for one day
gas prices are going to be this much
just protesting in the series because
iranian cannot drive we have to do what
we have to do
you know how hated trump was for what he
did so now you're china and we're the
enemy the three of us are representing
china
imagine we're on china's board the three
of us we're strategic no one knows about
us we're behind a close type of speakers
we don't want any attention we're
strategists
how do you what list think think
like you're china and you're behind
closed doors how do you take down
america to become number one
who's the number one enemy you have now
that you got to get rid of
trump how do you get rid of them we know
how to do it
how do we get rid of them who owes us
the most favors
who do we have the most dirt on biden
okay there you go buddy
it's not just biting but it's a list of
people he's one of them
but you go from the top and you work
your way down and typically you need to
have the people at the top
that owe you the biggest favors who has
the most influence because that's the
easiest ones to go through
by the way you sit there and you're
thinking like i think i want to be right
i'm hoping i'm 100 wrong i don't think
i'm wrong
i'm hoping i'm 100 wrong but this is the
dirty part about politics that you deal
with this
so you think from
2019 beyond even by because biden was
considering running in
um 2016. when hillary kind of boxed them
out at that point
yeah he was thinking about running back
then okay
huh timing wasn't good for him
but yeah but there's there's
conversation behind closers where
obama's when he sat down with biden said
it's clinton's turn
you can run next but right now let
calendar so in those four years
yeah before he ran yup you're saying
that's when the shady dealings
likely occurred no that's not what i'm
saying the shady dealing's been going on
for a while
even while he was vice president what
are you talking about
that's the whole thing with hunter what
was caught as he was getting favors when
biden was the vp
i thought a lot of that was in ukraine
china as well you're saying
of course hunter was taking advantage of
his last name
being biden yeah but but this is this is
the this is the part
so if he's fearful of these stories
being leaked like
we're leaking it right now right now
people people are talking we're talking
about this but there's a big you're
saying that the there's a mainstream
media there's a big difference between
you saying i think johnny
hooked up with mary versus mary coming
out and saying
he hooked up with me gotcha okay mary is
china the smoking gun
yeah mary's china mary's going to come
out and say he did hook up with us
and if biden would have let's say
hypothetically lost right like because
biden would have taken you back to 2019
he didn't win iowa he didn't win new
hampshire trump's next four years would
have been a
joke compared to the first four years
meaning it would have been the hardest
four years of his life
if trump would have won it would have
been the hardest four years of trump's
meaning if there was a different
candidate bernie sanders would have been
the candidate if
no bernie sanders cannot be bought by
okay that's my point is that you're
saying that china
china didn't want bernie sanders china
doesn't want to elizabeth warren or p
buddha
these are nobodies to them china wants
hillary china wants biden
china wants huh they want the political
lead they don't want any of these others
can you imagine what an easy mark
hunter biden was for china i mean a guy
that just
is morally compromised where you could
just throw
easy money at him and you own them
because
you would think at some point hunter
biden would think man this is a little
bit too good to be true these boards
really want me sitting
you know on them and collecting this
type of check there has to be something
else involved it's it's unbelievable how
much info they probably have on him
played right into it
look yeah stuff man yeah it's it's uh
it's the the
stories are this is nothing new
churchill
was the most hated guy in uk
but even the people at the top
who hated churchill knew there was only
one guy that could go up against
hitler it was only churchill let me say
that one more time yeah
churchill was hated he was hated
tremendously
he was an obnoxious guy he was annoying
he was trump's times a hundred
you have to realize churchill was a true
believer at the highest level
the stuff that this guy did at a young
age how many books did he write how many
think
the things churchill accomplished in his
lifetime there's a very few people that
are at his level by the way
very few people and he was cocky he was
arrogant
he was confident he was every single
word about an annoying person you can
put up
churchill was trump times 10 is who
churchill was
but they knew only one guy could go up
against hitler and it was him and what
happened
save the country we'd be talking german
right now you and i
our language will be german right now
cassie schnutz and that whole crew
exactly
that's the point we we the germans
you know they would be ruling the world
today if it wasn't for god like
churchill so
you have to be very careful with
personalities like
him like a trump you have to be very
careful with personalities like him
to not emotionally dislike her it's such
a hard yesterday i'm doing an interview
with this girl drop that gorgeous girl
was trying to introduce her to you like
this is a girl you guys
hooked me up no she had a boyfriend
already i'm like dude i want to
introduce her to you
so she's interviewing me i think she's
out of canada toronto
i think her name is mariano or something
like that right
and she's interviewing me and she asked
a question she says uh
she says how do you make your decisions
with uh being able to be reasonable
without letting your emotions get
involved
number one question i asked you what she
teed you up right into your wheelchair
i thought like she had talked to you or
something i'm like do you hang out with
adam obviously not but so
so so she says this question i'm like
okay it is very like for me
listen i did not like when obama came
out with obamacare
i didn't like it the reason why i didn't
like it because it was forced if we
would have waited a year later
we could have possibly had both sides
and had a different kind of a program it
was forced
let's get it through let's get it
through it's not going to be taxed and
then all of a sudden health insurance
industry gone
my insurance for the employees went up
to the roof 40 one year 40
next year 40 next i'm like dude this is
ridiculous what we have to pay to
employees
but i won't sit there and say obama
doesn't know how to play the game of
politics i wouldn't say
obama's not suave i can set aside
policies versus personality
trump's personality can be annoying
trump's personality can be very
frustrating trump's personality can be
unattractive
this guy thinks he's better than you in
everything he does in his life
if trump played you in basketball he
would probably think he's better than
you he probably thinks he's going to be
better than you matt
that's trump's mindset it's unattractive
to a lot of people
on the opposite side right but at the
same time
you want somebody going up against china
who do you want going up against china
if you got the number one enemy in the
world being china who do you want going
up against them
what kind of a personality do you want
going up against them somebody that
china fears or somebody that china
thinks they can get anything out of that
that's strategic questions you
you know those are things that you have
to sit there and think about and say
well you know
i don't know you know i may want to have
this guy go out there and sit down have
those conversations with me
anyways what do you think they're
gearing up their military for
japan oh just owning that part of the
globe
all over the south china sea is
obviously a big thing that they're
concerned about building
i think they've built the island listen
why do you buy life insurance policy
because you're planning on killing
yourself next day
no why do we buy auto insurance because
we're trying to kill our you know go
into a car accident the next day
just thinking there is just just in case
that you it's just to tell you okay
come on come on come on you want to go
let's go
come on u.s come on see what we got
see what we got test us and see what's
going to take place
very big yesterday i interviewed saddam
hussein's sons double
they died july 22nd of all three they
died so they died three years before
saddam got killed in december vote six
so but anyway so i'm interviewing
uh the scandinavian latif who's who day
is double
okay and you're sitting there hearing
the stories of how they play these games
oh my gosh it is a dirty game how these
guys play these games
but half the battle is what you better
know what i'm capable of
china's trying to tell the world try us
try us in cyber warfare
try us in bio warfare try us in direct
warfare
try us in innovation try us in
technology
try us and manufacture and try us they
want the monopoly they want it all
they want it all and they got a nearly a
couple billion people
of inventory to be dealing with fyi when
you're talking about a
joe biden we are we're so focused on
fighting
with each other that we're missing
really who the true enemy is and
and china's just sitting there just yeah
is there any solace in knowing we can
beat them in basketball
i actually don't think that's even going
to happen i think even basketball
china's going to
great oh not in the game of basketball
but i think controlling the nba that's
right not in the game of basketball
i think china knows because
look lebron just got paid what two years
85 million
you know what happens if nba was being
played in china every day you know what
his
salary would have been it would have
been two years 200 million lebron would
have been 100.
if howard stern's making 100 million
dollar contract for seven years they're
about to sign him at 60 some years old
you don't think lebron's worth a hundred
million dollars well yes if we're in
china
yeah can you imagine if they say we're
in china now next superstar is coming up
they're getting a 10-year billion dollar
contract yes if you're in china that
would happen
so imagine behind closed doors adam
silver and these nba owners are saying
guys you know when it comes down to
china let's not talk a lot of smack
about china because
you could be the first to get a
billionaire i'm actually being that
serious
so you got that big of a mark you saw
what happened with daryl mori and the
houston rockets
there you go exactly and hardin still
didn't show up to yesterday to practice
about that he's holding out so you guys
got if you
if you for one second underestimate the
power of china you are naive by the way
let me give a quick shout out
to one of our sponsors hawthorne uh
hawthorne is somebody i decided to do a
sponsorship with and again i told the
story a couple weeks ago
you know adam comes up to me one day and
say hey listen these guys who do
you know soap skin products all this
stuff
do you want to do sponsorship i laughed
at adam i said adam what are you talking
about
you want you want me to do sponsorship
with you know
a skim product i'm not do go talk to
somebody else i wouldn't do something
with pat i'm just telling you try this
out
the box sits here for how many weeks it
was there for a couple weeks for a
couple of weeks so finally
when you're gonna try this can you just
go try this by the way last night you
texted me texted to me a little too late
i didn't try it out last night the other
stuff that you told me
he's saying put the hawthorne picture up
here or something
so so then i go home and i try to
shampoo the soap
everything and i felt like i hate to say
this man i feel like a
you know a girl who can't wait to wash
her face every night because my wife it
could be two o'clock in the morning
we're coming home
she's gonna take a shower she's gonna
wash her face no matter what happens she
has to do it
i'm like that now no matter what happens
i come home i have to take a shower
i have to use my hawthorne shampoo i
have to use my hawthorne soap
i have to use my hawthorne face wash i
am in love my challenge to anybody
that's listening to this
look how many times have you seen this
do sponsorships we don't do it all the
time
just go buy this thing and test it out
for yourself and see what happens
see how you feel about i took a shower
last night with hawthorne this morning
hawthorne just so you know
it's a hawthorne family right now i got
the hand i am in love with hawthorne so
if you've never done anything with
hawthorne just a couple things you do
you can go take a quiz
they ask a few basic questions give you
some examples like
you know what's your favorite drink you
know how do you spend a night out you
know what do you do do you smoke etc
they ask you all these questions
after they do that they come out with a
result and tell you exactly what's for
you
and you're able to go use their products
and if you want to find out more about
their products
we got they got some special offers for
holiday christmas that's coming up
you can go to hawthorne.com once again
hawthorne that's h-a-w
t-h-o-r-n-e dot co not com
dot co c-o so hawthorne dot co
check out their special holiday offers
that they have
co that's h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e dot c-o-k
let's put their
website in the comment section and in
the description section
so people can go take advantage their
products i'm a fan i'm a big big fan of
hawthorne
after having used their products so
let's talk about trump
to sign america first executive order
on covet 19 and maybe out of that story
i'd much rather talk about trump
confirms he'll run for president 2024
and he's talking about a big launch i
don't know if you guys heard about this
or not
he wants to he wants to go out with a
bank he wants to go tell the world on
the same day
when uh uh what do you call it a biden's
conversation yeah
so trump is reportedly planning a made
for tv exit on air force one from the
white house
to rally on inauguration day hoping to
pull viewers from biden president trump
is planning a made for tv exit
sources told the outlet that trump is
planning to fly to florida
on air force one to stage a rally at the
same time biden sworn in
at a socially distanced inauguration in
dc that would break with inauguration
day traditions designed to showcase the
stability u.s democracy
biden said last week that he personally
didn't care if trump attended his
inauguration but trump should go to
demonstrate a peaceful transfer of power
and trump has plans for the next four
years two
bash biden on a daily basis and make his
life a living hell
for the next four years to show what
they did to him trump wants to return
the favor
back to biden and then afterwards he
wants to run 2024
and he's planning on running and
campaigning for office the next
four years what are your thoughts
straight hold on yeah
trump lost the election he's leaving i
don't understand yet it's an if hold on
tom what's going on here he's already
planning on going to mar-a-lago and he's
already planning on doing this air force
one thing
i think he needs to make sure that he
actually doesn't
lose this election first i don't like
the fact that he seems like he's
conceding i don't like that at all
i know your heart is appointing me i
think he needs to try to hold it
together adam you've shown your true
colors too easily
i think he needs to keep fighting i
think he's got this thing
um i know you're at 33 percent
41 tom's at 41 you know
if he somehow loses i don't know how he
would lose
but if trump somehow loses this is the
trumpiest move ever
in the middle of an an inauguration
making it all about trump
forget about america forget about an
inauguration forget about a peaceful
transfer of power
let's make it all about trump let's make
it all about
everything trump forget about america
let's just what's your point though
what's your point
this is just it's obvi like
all beings in all seriousness if you
lose you lost bro
like this is like just if if georgia
does a recount yeah you know he's making
fun of brian kemp now
if arizona does a recount he loses
pennsylvania does a recount
at some point you know rudy giuliani i
know he's doing a great job right now if
he has no evidence
and he has nothing no merit and he loses
every single case
and you actually lose they count every
legal vote and you actually lose
at what point are you just a sore loser
at what point at what point do you say
look
as an american i have something i
believe i believe in american democracy
um and be uh for the for the good of the
country betterment of the country yeah
the betterment of the country
good luck with freaking sleepy joe i
lost but i'll be back in four years
this is not about me this is about
america but you know
i'll see you in four years this is not
about me but if trump
of course trump does not have that in
his body everything's about trump
so even on an aggravation day he's going
to make it about himself i think he's
going to rent the goodyear blimp
fly over the inauguration and moon
everybody i think that would be one of
the things that's not a grown-up move
you know here's the thing when you think
of donald trump he and i wrote this
yesterday in vt post
he named a 747 after himself casinos
after himself a gold-plated hotel after
himself
a university after himself if you don't
think he's going to do something
unorthodox on inauguration day you don't
know donald trump he definitely is
here's the key phrase joe biden says
break with tradition
screw tradition they broke with
tradition by harassing him for four
years
and whatever had taken place in this
last election
with voter fraud quote unquote that's
breaking with tradition where we don't
count every vote
okay that's the biggest break with
tradition the other thing too is can you
imagine how happy
cnn and msnbc and the new york times and
everybody else would be if donald trump
did decide to
run for the 24 election and declare it
right away they'd actually have
something they could cover they'd be
relevant
again for the next four years and
finally i think trump's into doing
things that have never been done before
and i think him coming back in 2024 to
say i told you so
it would be the easiest mess for him to
fix and to clean up and i think
he kind of is attracted to the scenario
of let biden bury the country and
himself and he'll come in
and save the day in 2024. okay let's
process this let's process this on
his decision to not want to show up okay
not want to show up and do his own thing
uh number one breaking tradition you're
right the tradition was
the uh sitting president doesn't get
criticized by the former president
that he replaced okay well bite obama
broke that tradition because for four
years all by all
obama did is trash trump every single
day he had an opportunity to talk bad
about trump he did it regularly not
something bush did to him
but something he did to trump and a lot
of democrats said trump was doing the
same thing to obama
i mean he was but he wasn't but obama
was doing that to bush all the time
every time something came up obama would
say well i inherited a very good
relationship
but wait a minute but because of bush
not because of obama
because of bush not because of obama
they have a great relation because of
bush you think it's bush only not
of course it is because bush not once
said anything negative about obama
but obama said so many bad things about
trump bush never said anything
the ironic part is trump likes to say
that he inherited a mess from obama
obama did i say that no i'm saying
that's what trump said yeah but i didn't
say that although i honestly say he
inherited a message
i'll let you finish it i'll let you
finish okay so my point to you is
obama broke the tradition of trashing
the current president he couldn't help
himself and obama kept doing that over
and over again and when
when trump tweeted and said obama has to
be the worst president of all time and
on jimmy kimmel or jimmy fallon he was
reading the tweets mean tweets
and obama said at least i'll go into
history books as a president and drums
to mike
in and out of dinner obama makes fun of
trump for 20 minutes
while trump was at the dinner and
sitting right in front of him yeah
okay so i'm sorry buddy this is that
obama
caused a lot of before trump was even
obama caused
a lot of this to himself okay so he
didn't do the classy thing himself so
let's take tradition on that part's
cancelling both sides out
that's gone forget about tradition that
part's gone here's the next one
why doesn't he want to be there is it a
business deal
meaning does he want to go do a splash
media company here's what i'm doing i'm
going to compete with cnn fox all this
sunset
i don't know i mean let's just say he
does that
is he gonna build a hundred billion
dollar company over the next five years
i don't think so
is he interested on taking his network
from three billion to twenty billion
what the hell is the difference
what is the difference between being
worth three million no one would believe
it anyway
no no but the difference what is the
difference between being worth 3 billion
and 20 billion nothing
you still get to go do the same thing 17
billion no but the what is the
difference you still get to buy the 200
million
home you still get to go to all the nice
restaurants you still afford a 747
private
plane for yourself you still it's the
same thing life's going to be good
either way life's going to be
better at three or so is he trying to
get that additional 17 billion what the
hell is that going to do to his legacy
i don't think that's what he's going to
do so then it leaves me to what
is it a trump thing that he doesn't like
losing publicly and he's trying to save
face okay i for sure see that because i
i don't think he likes losing
at all so he's going to try to save face
but he's lost many times in his career
he's lost a football league that he had
anything about herschel walker
and he lost that he had the atlantic
city what he did over there he lost that
airline casinos airlines stakes but
nothing like this
trump university it's like you lost not
your company
real estate but he's lost he's lost many
many times he's also lost many many
times
so you don't become who he is without
having lost many times
and he's sitting there saying this guy's
a billion dollar in debt all that
he's lost many many times okay or here's
the last one
here's the last one or he
really believes america's
exceptionalism and the american dream
could potentially be lost
and he really sees these other guys
as enemies that could empower china a
lot because he learned a lot in the last
four years of what china's dealings are
and what other countries are really
doing and he's such a firm believer now
that his number one enemy is to go up
and make sure america stays at the top
and stays at as that country i said
maybe
these are the things i didn't tell you
what i know what's what
i said these are possibilities of what's
really going on
if it's the one that's about me z i know
i got four minutes i'm good with that if
it's about me well then he's gonna lose
legacy's not gonna be good to him if
it's about me alone if that's at the top
if it's about we and it's about his true
beliefs that he has that he wants to go
out and fight for that part of america
well the legacy is going to benefit him
if he makes it and he wins 2024
and he goes back and we see how much
advancement china makes over the next
four years because here's the reality of
it
if during the biden administration china
becomes number one
that's on china that's on biden's legacy
as well if during biden's administration
china becomes number one
it's going to be the easiest thing for
trump to come in saying during his reign
china took over and became number one
then trump's going to come in to say
he's the only one that can go up against
china
again i'm setting this up i don't know
if this is the case or not
all i'm saying is if that's the reason
why he's doing what he's doing more
power to him if it's for me
it's not going to be and by the way
there's some jokes online talking about
i think you brought it up saying
imagine if trump and trump run trump
senior runs as president trump jr runs
as vp
that's like nepotism at the highest
level if that was to ever take place
but no one knows what's going to happen
the next way i think that was your
prediction
that is my prediction i believe it will
happen because he wants to keep it going
forward he wants to save the republican
party for the long term
uh and he can blame pence a little bit
too you could say that didn't work
oh i actually think pence he needs a
pence
i think he definitely that's right
when we had the martina booth here
what'd she say she said you know
she respects pence a lot she doesn't
respect trump
so so a pence is if you have a trump
trump what am i voting for
right you need a different people but we
are talking about donald trump like it's
the reason biden picked the comments
right now trump jr is about to become
the president of uh np
uh uh well not uh npr what's the nra nra
he's about to be the president
that's what he's working on because
their family supports a lot of these
beliefs
so i got i got to give one push back on
one thing yeah
and touche you're right about obama he
tried him you know
at least obama had trump to the white
house
look man let's be grown-ups i don't like
you you don't like me
cool you've trashed me
bro there's a big butt adam please
there's a big butt don't stop it
what how much hard time did the the
media give obama for eight years
zero zero he was every article was
is obama the greatest president of all
time could obama be one the greatest
president of all time
voters are saying 62 percent believe
that obama's greatest
president of all time how much of that
have you seen anything for what
he got a nobel prize three months after
being a president what did he do
so media what does that have to do with
trump showing up to
everything because for four years all
the media did is trash this guy nonstop
it's non-stop embarrassing and
humiliating him for four
straight years russia was a hoax the
dossier was a hoax by hillary clinton
no one covered it because it's not
necessary to cover
you know how pissed off anybody would be
if they manipulated and played games
like that with you for four years
i don't care who you are you could be
the biggest saint in the world that's
going to bother you
so tradition wise oh it is what it is
but
everybody broke a little bit of
tradition here the last four years ain't
nobody has saints not on the left cool
not on the right no i i think he needs
to show up oh no no no
yeah i think he needs to show up but i
understand why he's doing it
i think he needs to show up but i think
i understand if you were in here
his ear you'd be like look first of all
if i would my approach would be a
different approach but i'm not trump i
can't speak on behalf of a human being
how the guy's wired
the guy's been like that for 74 years
when people say what advice would you
give to trump
nothing the guy got to where he got at
74 years old on his way of thinking you
are not going to be able to tell the guy
what to do and by the way
he can't win either way they'd hammer
him if he went yeah so anyways
having said that i really enjoyed
today's podcast by the way a bunch of
people give a hundred dollars today
thank you to godwil
gil you give a hundred bucks twice oh
joseph carter
what are your thoughts on living in
puerto rico for five months for the four
percent federal
tax and living in florida and risk
entertainment a lot of people i know
that do it including peter schiff
and obviously the pharmacy that gave uh
the other number that gave up guys if
you enjoyed today's podcast
smash that subscribe button for us we
will not be doing any podcast this week
i got a lot of travels and different
meetings that's going on
but i believe we're coming back next
week we're not going to do any other
podcast this week
but we will do it next week i know many
of you guys are asking about us doing
this on a daily basis
my current schedule does not permit but
maybe one day take care everybody love
you bye bye bye
maybe one day
you